hi
my name's greg coolgan and i'm an
architect with apogee at google cloud
hi i'm dino chieza i'm a colleague of
greg's
on the apogee team at google cloud
so i'm very excited to be here today to
talk to you about some means of securing
your apis
there are a couple key points we hope
you take away from this session
one api security is not one size fits
all
depending on the purpose of the api the
audience the data etc
there'll be varying techniques you may
use to protect that api
while there are certainly some things we
view as base requirements for example
transport layer security
the approaches we talk about are
designed to be layered and used where
appropriate
two security is not static what works
today
may need to adapt tomorrow three
tools like apogee can help manage the
security of your apis
dino and i frequently talk to customers
about api security
over the past few years the number of
tax that we see
and the number of conversations we have
about security have been steadily
increasing
securing access this is generally what i
believe most of us think about when we
think api security
making sure that we have authentication
and authorization in place
as the slide states the caller presents
something and the receiver checks to see
if access should be granted
in basically all cases you'll want to
use tls to secure the connection
also known as one-way tls
so let's talk about a few means of
actually securing your access
first api key i really think of an api
key more as a way to identify calling
out than a true security mechanism
though it's often a building block for
security mechanisms such as oauth
oauth is a very commonly used method of
authentication and authorization
it has allowances to let a consumer
authenticate their account and improve
access for certain parts of their
account
we've all gone through this
authorization flow where you log into an
account with an app
it redirects you to another login such
as your google login
and asks whether you grant the app
permissions to access your data
in one-way tls which is another means of
securing
the client identifies the server with
the certificate presented by that server
with a two-way tls connection the server
similarly identifies the client
tls certificates for clients can be
difficult to manage and they generally
aren't used with open api programs
though they are certainly used for some
partners that may access privileged apis
often in conjunction with other
authentication mechanisms for example
third-party payment processors may be
using a bank's actual payment apis
often have to have their servers present
client certificates as part of their
access
like i already mentioned api key is
really used for its simplicity we highly
recommend oauth
there are different grant types that can
be utilized based on the level of trust
and other requirements
a simple client credentials grant type
where a system passes a client id and a
secret might work well
for a trusted internal system a
third-party app that allows access to
individual data on the other hand would
need to use an authorization code flow
like i previously described where the
consumer authorizes the access
finally i'll mention that tls certs used
for two-way tls
make a lot of sense when you're using a
service mesh that can manage all of that
for you
one of the things in common with all of
these methods is that they identify the
calling client
oauth tokens however can also identify
not just the client but the end user as
well
so dino what situations do you see
customers using these different
mechanisms to secure their api access
well the api key is a good basic
building block
it's appropriate for use with an open
api where you want to track who's
calling the api
and also it can be used as a key
identifier
when doing signing or encryption i'll
talk
more about that later oauth is pretty
common as you said
most api gateways will just support it
it's a really good idea
two-way tls that's going to work for
devices that are
managed point-of-sale terminals devices
that you
control not so easy for consumer mobile
devices
or even partner systems
great what about json web tokens or jots
can i use those for authorization access
sure you can
jwt is just a special kind of token
oauth bearer tokens are commonly opaque
a random string
no information is inherent within that
string jwt is different it
encodes actual claims with an opaque
token
only the authorization server that
issued the token can resolve
that token into a set of claims or
entitlements
in contrast any system can decode and
verify the information
in assigned jwt so yes
jwt can be used as a bearer token to
support authorization checks and it may
be more flexible
and preferred in some cases
when to use each as always
it depends that's a larger conversation
uh spoken like a true architect it
depends i've used that phrase many times
myself
now let's talk about securing your api
messages themselves
i've worked with a customer that was
dealing with consumer credit information
as you might imagine they are passing
around personally identifiable
information that we would all prefer not
be leaked
they use things like tls and oauth of
course but in addition they actually
chose to pass some incoming payloads as
a
jwt using json web encryption for those
transactions gave them an extra layer of
security even if someone got a valid
oauth token
they still needed to sign and encrypt
the message itself
at a high level there are really two key
items when it comes to message security
signatures and encryption signatures
provide message integrity and
non-repudiation
basically a signature can contain a hash
of the message and is often signed using
a secret only the signer possesses
but can be verified by the receiver in
this way we can verify that the message
hasn't been altered
and has actually been sent by the
intended sender signatures don't provide
any privacy for the message though
for that you need encryption a
combination of signatures and encryption
can be used to protect sensitive data
hmac is also used pretty widely by cloud
providers for example in gcp you can
create a side url
that allows distributed access to a
storage bucket
using encryption can be useful if you
want to protect against things like a
tls vulnerability
that would allow an attacker to view
data in flight it can also be useful to
limit who is able to see data as it
moves between systems or when stored on
disk along the way
generally speaking this is only going to
be used for your most sensitive data
this leads me to another question do you
know do you have any recommendations for
when folks should use these different
message security mechanisms
sure here are a few first keep it simple
signing or encryption necessarily means
more work for client developers
and more complexity take care to apply
it thoughtfully
second application layer signing or
encryption
helps protecting information across
multiple hops
in a chain third select the signing
approach that fits your team so hmac rsa
whichever they're most comfortable with
and don't forget jwt can be used to sign
or encrypt
payloads not just id tokens in
all these cases you're going to need to
think about key management
last include a timestamp in the signed
payload to protect
against replays jwt will help you with
this
if you use hmac or rsa you will have to
come up with your own
convention
great thanks dino securing conversations
even with other security measures in
place sometimes attackers create
accounts to try to mimic human users and
gain access
rarely though do these attacks follow
the same patterns as normal use
securing conversations generally makes
use of modern technology like machine
learning
to consider usage patterns and
potentially identify malicious traffic
this is where we start to get into
things like bots there are plenty of
bots with bad intent
it can take advanced features to help
identify and prevent this type of attack
there are a few things in the toolkit
for securing conversations one of the
simplest can be rate limiting
it's unlikely for example that a human
will be requesting a new token
several times a second or even more than
once a minute
anomaly detection has also seen an
uptake with customers that i support
as we talked about sometimes bad actors
get through and can and that can change
the error rate or the overall rate of
traffic even
anomaly detection applies machine
learning models to understand what a
normal traffic flow looks like and can
alert when things like the error rate
are outside of normal
this is all done without anyone actually
configuring a specific alert
security teams have come to rely on
these alerts as a potential indicator
that a bad actor is bypassing other
security mechanisms
it also works great to alert potential
operational issues i've had more than
one customer that has told me anomaly
detection has helped them detect an
error
alert the target service that was having
the issue and fix it all before they
broke their slo
you'll also see recaptcha up here
usually when i think of recaptcha
i think of having to click on the
annoying images or maybe type some
difficult to read characters
hey dino how could recaptcha help with
securing apis
good question so in the original version
of recaptcha
a web page presents the familiar are you
a robot
challenge google released version three
of recaptcha in 2018
in that version it now relies on device
and endpoint fingerprinting there's no
ui
that means both web pages and apis can
be protected by the same system
the client needs to connect to the
recaptcha server to get a token
that client uses that token in its
request for an api token
the api server can then validate the
recaptcha token
before granting service and recaptcha
will issue an opinion about that client
is it a robot or is it not using
recapture this way
recaptcha acts as a gatekeeper or
bouncer for your front door
it does mean introducing a new external
dependency
into your system but you may want to
accept that to get the additional level
of security
perfect thank you
so when do you use what api access token
pretty much is always going to be in
place there are some exceptions for
truly public info
but even then you may want to provide
some level of access control
signatures can be useful when you need
to verify the integrity of the payload
or can even be used for distributed
access like the sign url example
encryption is useful when a message may
be passed around between multiple
systems in an asynchronous manner
or for the most sensitive data you want
to ensure that even if the wires are
compromised the content is still secure
this can also be used to ensure that
messages are secure even when written to
disk or if they're inadvertently written
to logs
there are multiple areas where
anomalated bot detection might make
sense
but we recommend that this is at least
used to protect your login and token api
ideally you want to prevent the bad
actors from ever getting a token in the
first place
with that let me turn it over to dino
who walk us through how we might be able
to implement some of this inside of
apigee
information driven companies will have
tens or hundreds of services that they
use to run their business
some of them custom built maybe in java
golang c sharp
python maybe running in a vm or in
kubernetes some of these services
might be third party sas there are many
different
implementation options apogee can help
manage all of them
to do that we rely on an apogee proxy
that intercedes between clients of the
service
and the service this allows us to
standardize
on the access message and conversation
security
for this demonstration i have a single
upstream service
it's implemented in node
it uses express it's javascript
and all those details don't matter the
key detail
is that it exposes an
http api so let me show you what it
looks like to invoke that
the service is running locally i have my
dev instance
and you can see it's a inventory and
product management service i can query
it and get information about products
you can see
anvil birdseed a bunch of other products
this is just the dev instance i also
have it running
in google app engine so let's try to
invoke it there there's a different url
i'll send the same request and you can
see i'm getting a 401
unauthorized the service is locked down
to enforce api management we must ensure
that the service is accessible only
through
the api gateway we can do that with
two-way tls
firewall configuration with ip
restrictions uh or via some other
mechanism apogee then acts as the
enforcement point for clients no client
can reach the service
except through the apogee proxy so let
me show you a proxy that
stands in front of this particular uh
service so here we see the target of the
proxy and this is the ingress
endpoint for the api proxy the proxy
itself
is just a pass-through uh it receives
the request and then proxies to the
upstream so let me turn on tracing and
then we'll flip back and we'll invoke
not the google app engine endpoint but
the proxy endpoint in apigee
you can see i'm sending that same
request and it's actually connecting to
that
app engine instance which because it's
apogee it's allowing it through and you
can see i've got a trace statement here
the request is received and then it's
proxied to the
upstream target so really nice except
apogee is merely acting as a
pass-through
we want the proxy to do more so in order
to illustrate that let's stop the trace
we'll deploy version 12
of this proxy which includes
a verify access token policy so now
we're going to start doing oauth
enforcement in the proxy
again let me turn on a trace and then
i'm going to run that same request
and you should see apogee saying hey
unauthorized
you did not pass a token so i'm not
going to let you in
how can we get a token apogee also acts
as a token dispensary
and i have another proxy for that this
is an apogee
oauth proxy that generates uh tokens for
the client credentials grant type
so i'm going to turn on trace for that
and now we'll request uh
a token using client credentials so
that's a different api request
and you can see i'm sending that into
apogee and yep i've got
an access token coming back so that's
really good in the trace you can see
apogee handled that request
it verified the client credentials and
then generated a token which is now good
for
30 minutes we now have the token
let's invoke the service again we'll
switch back to the other proxy
we'll invoke the service again passing
that valid token
and now you can see apogee is receiving
the request it includes the valid token
and i'm getting the
product inventory information so that's
just what we want
what if i use an expired access token
something that's out of date um i also
want to
check that out want to make sure that
access tokens get rejected
when they are expired and sure enough
apogee is sending back
hey that token is old that's expired
it's doing exactly what we wanted to do
let's try an update
uh for for this uh part of the
demonstration i have a payload
i want to send a post in the payload
looks like that
and i've configured the apogee proxy in
here
to check the hmac on that payload
to prevent replays and to ensure greater
message security
something we talked about a little bit
earlier so let's
um let's try to send that in send in
a post with that update
uh with that payload as an update and
you can see apogee is sending hey you
need to
send an hmac for that request which is
again what we want let's try sending in
that request
with an an invalid hmac the the wrong
hmac for this payload
and you can see now apogee is saying ah
well you sent in an hmac but
uh it was the wrong hmac that hmac did
not succeed and here's the one where we
didn't
include an hmac here's apogee handling
the request where we did send an hmac
but it was the wrong one
this is the actual correct hmac value
that apogee is expecting
for this given payload this is the value
that i sent so let's send
the correct value
hmac equals that value and we'll send
that same request again
with the correct value and now apogee
says yep that's good that post
uh we've validated it apogee has
validated it
um the hmac passed and then it proxies
to the upstream
the upstream system did not have to
concern itself with tokens or hmacs
apogee is doing all that work
for you so i didn't show it here but
remember you'll want to include
timestamps in your hmacs
to prevent replays
in the prior examples the client used a
client credentials grant type passing in
the client id and secret
in the basic auth header in order to get
a token
how about using a jwt as an alternative
instead of passing a client id in secret
the token endpoint in apigee can require
that the client
signs the request for token
uh using a key pair provisioned just for
this client and we can use as
the signing mechanism uh jwt that's
standard
so how do we do that first we'll get a
jwt
uh and i'll use this webpage to
generate uh assigned jwt using the
private key that is associated to this
client
let me grab that jwt and we'll set that
as a
shell variable now i want to open up
the um the jwt token dispensary
i'm going to turn on tracing there
and then we're going to send in a
request for a token that passes that jwt
so here's a new request for token
passing in the jwt that i just set
here's the grant type it's a jwt bearer
grant type
and now i've got an opaque access token
in exchange for that signed uh assertion
from the client
and that opaque token will work just
like
a token issued with client credentials
grant type
so that's going to work just as expected
what if we use a jwt id
token to get uh
as an exchange for a bearer token so
here
this is a page that allows me to sign in
using google sign-in which is just an
open id connect
provider and what that means is it will
issue an id token to an app that allows
a
person to sign in so now i've got a jwt
from google that's much bigger it's got
a lot more claims in it you can see some
of the claims here are decoded
the email address name a url for my
picture and so on
uh what if we use that to try to get a
token
uh we we can do that here with a new uh
different api proxy so this one rather
than verifying a self-signed
jwt from a client it's going to verify
that this is a token issued by google
sign in
you can use any open id connect provider
octa off xero azure
google sign in there are lots of other
options but
any of them will have that same kind of
approach with the jwks
endpoint so let me try now obtaining a
token uh
with uh with that jwt
we use a different endpoint and sure
enough i'm getting
now an access token in exchange for an
id
token so that's a really nice capability
in apogee and you can see the flow in
apogee
allowing that verifying that request and
issuing the token back and again that
token will work just like any other
token
issued by apogee how about something a
little different
what if we want apogee to accept a jwt
directly so i've got a different api
proxy endpoint for that
this one accepts a jwt and it just
verifies that jwt
again this will be an id token issued by
google so we'll turn on tracing for that
api proxy
and uh invoke that
and you can see the api proxy
is now accepting the jwt as an input
token
and it's verifying that directly so no
opaque token rather it's the the full
id token issued by uh google sign in
and as i said you can use any open id
connect provider
to allow that to happen last thing i
want to show
is what about if we want to protect the
token dispensary endpoint with
recaptcha and i've got another
api proxy here that does that so again
this is a client credentials
token dispensary in apogee but it
protects
the request with recaptcha and the way
this works
will become clear after i show you the
client page looks like
this so this is a bit of
javascript that runs in a browser and it
uses the
recaptcha uh sdk
from google here uh i use the client to
obtain a token a recaptcha token
uh using the recaptcha site key then
after i the client gets the recaptcha
token
it can send in a request for uh an
api token to apigee passing in the
recapture token as part of that request
then apogee in the proxy will verify
that recapture token it does that here
before issuing a client credentials
grant uh grant type token so let's see
this all work
uh i've got the page uh running that and
i'll just click this button
it's obtaining the token from uh
recaptcha
sending that along with the client
credentials grant into
apogee and you can see that
apogee received that request
and verified the token
google replied with uh a response for
that token giving it a score
of uh 0.9 which
is sufficient so um the apogee toke
apogee proxy
issues the token as it did in all those
other cases
and that's it i hope that gives you a
good idea
of some of the things that you can do
with apogee for access security message
security and conversation security
okay those demonstrations i hope give
you an idea of some of the possibilities
apigee offers for securing your apis
focusing on securing access securing the
messages
themselves and monitoring and securing
patterns of messages
so now i'll turn it back to greg to
bring it home for us
awesome thanks dino great demo today we
learned about different ways you can
secure access
most commonly using tokens you can
secure your api messages with signatures
and encryption
and finally how advanced features such
as anomaly detection and recaptcha can
help secure your conversations
you saw these different techniques can
be applied differently to different apis
briefly see how you could actually
implement some of these for this
functionality
quickly and easily using apigee i want
to truly thank you for watching this
session
and offer to continue the conversation
i've set up some expert one-on-one
sessions over the next couple of weeks
we will also be answering your questions
in the question and answer section
for this session thank you very much